so what we have here is x being defined
in terms of t and y being defined in
terms of t and then if you were to plot
over all of the t values you get a
pretty cool plot just like this so you
try t equals zero figure out what x and
y are t is equal to one figure out what
x and y are and all the other t's and
then you get this pretty cool looking
graph but our the goal in this video
isn't just to appreciate the coolness of
graphs or curves defined by parametric
equations but we actually want to do
some calculus and in particular we want
to find the derivative
we want to find the derivative of y with
respect to x
the derivative of y with respect to x
when t
when
t is equal to
negative one-third and if you are
inspired i encourage you to pause and
and try to solve this and i am about to
do it with you if you in case you you
already did or you just want me to all
right so the key is is well how do you
find the derivative with respect to
x derivative of y with respect to x when
they're both defined in terms of t
and the key realization
is the derivative of y
with respect to x
with respect to x is going to be equal
to
is going to be equal to the derivative
of y with respect to t
over the derivative of x with respect to
t
if you were to view these differentials
as numbers well this would actually work
out that work out mathematically now it
gets a little bit non-rigorous when you
start to do that but if you thought of
it that it's an easy way of thinking
about why this actually might make sense
the derivative of something versus
something else is equal to the
derivative of y with respect to t over x
with respect to t
all right so how does that help us well
we can figure out the derivative of x
with respect to t and derivative of y
with respect to t
the derivative of x with respect to t
is just going to be equal to
let's see the derivative of the outside
with respect to the inside it's going to
be 2
sine whoops derivative of sine is cosine
2 cosine of 1 plus 3t
times the derivative of the inside with
respect to t so that's going to be
derivative of 1 is just 0. derivative of
3t with respect to t is 3. so times
3. that's the derivative of x with
respect to d i just use the chain rule
here derivative of the outside 2 sine of
something with respect to the inside
so derivative of this outside 2 sine of
something with respect to 1 plus 3t is
that right over there and the derivative
of the inside with respect to t is just
our 3.
now derivative of y with respect to t is
a little bit more straightforward
derivative of y with respect to t we
just apply the power rule here
3 times 2 is 6 t to the 3 minus 1 power
6 t squared
so this is going to be equal to
six
t squared
over
well we have the two times the three so
we have six
times cosine
of one plus three t
and then our sixes cancel out and we are
left with
we are left with
t squared
over
cosine of one plus three t
and if we care when t is equal to
negative one third when t is equal to
negative one third this is going to be
equal to
well this is going to be equal to
negative one third squared negative one
third
squared
over
over the cosine of
1 plus 3 times negative 1 3 is negative
1 so it's 1 plus negative 1 so it's the
cosine of 0. and the cosine of 0 is just
going to be 1. so this is going to be
equal to positive
positive 1 9. and let's see if we can
visualize what's going on here so let me
draw a little table here
so
so i'm going to plot i'm going to think
about t and x and y
so t
and x
and y so when t is equal to
negative one third
well our x is going to be this is going
to be sine of zero so our x is going to
be 0 and our y is going to be what 2
over
or negative 2 over 27
so we're talking about
we are talking about the point 0 comma
negative 2 over 27
so that is that point right over there
so that's the point where we're trying
to find the slope of the tangent line
and it's telling us that that slope is
one-ninth that slope is one-ninth so if
we move
i guess one way to think about is if we
move four one two three four and a half
we're going to move up half
so
if i wanted to draw the tangent line
right there it would look
something like
something like that
something
something like that let's see if we go
one two three four and a half so yeah
just like
that is pretty close so that's what we
just figured out we figured out that the
slope of the tangent line right at that
point is 1 9. so it's not only
neat to look at but i guess somewhat
useful